this season in FIFA 16 we're focused on
three big things to create a beautiful
football experience we're innovating
across the entire pitch to give fans
balanced and exciting gameplay and we're
helping every fan compete at a higher
level with FIFA trainer an all new
in-game training system finally we're
bringing new and exciting ways to play
play fifa in your favorite modes and for
the first time ever women's national
teams are in our game to build on this
story of people 16 I'm here to tell you
about exclusive news fans playing on
xbox that news is all about two things
speed for ultimate team and EA access
but is the plays fans go to live out
their footballing dreams it's the most
popular mode in FIFA play by millions of
fans on any given day and we all know
Xbox players love their fun so what's
coming this season only on xbox you'll
have more fun legends to create the
ultimate squad see new legends adding
more iconic players and we'll meet them
soon we're also making it easier view to
fit legends in your team with all new
legends chemistry every player will
match leagues with legends and now you
only need two pair nationality to create
strong connections on the pitch
so if you're building a squad with
legend Javier Zanetti it right back
he'll have a good connection with
Raphael Varane but an even stronger
connection with his fellow Argentinean
Leo Messi this gives you more
combinations to build that ultimate
squad only on xbox and that is what you
want better squads and better players
and we'll start you on that path with
massive news of fans playing on xbox
we're giving a legend player on
three-game loan to everyone who plays
fifa ultimate team on xbox this season
now I want to tell you about the
benefits of EA access members get to
play first play more and play for less
only on xbox one but fans this is a big
deal for you the a axis X members say
ten percent on fifa ultimate team points
and you can put this to use when
searching for that perfect legend and
members get to play first in FIFA 16
getting the game up to a week early for
a limited time before it even hits the
shelves here on sep tember the 24 so
this season you can play first on Xbox
one with EA access
play with EA access and save up to ten
percent in fast and play with legends
only on xbox let's meet those new
legends right now are the stadium as one
stands to applaud the fantastic talent
credibly successful goalkeeper Victor
Bayer
great tackle from gattuso
and the area let me know there's a
scorer that was an elegant finish
well he's a clever midfield player
got the tall again such a strong Tattler
having a genetic
oh that he's silky smooth in the
Welshman
real classic Italian defender alessandro
nesta
there's a goal from George bath well
what is the privilege and see that kind
of finish the what is a legend